you and your sister are showing the skin
tonight in the most classy elegant way i
love that thank you i love your dress
thank you what was the vibe you wanted
to go for tonight so it's very
comfortable it's warm girl so i'm just
going for warm and comfort and
just
celebrating my sister
you know
the love that you guys have the
sisterhood that you have and the way
that you always show up to support each
other and your solo endeavors is amazing
how proud of her are you tonight i am so
proud of my sister tonight everyone's
going to be blown away once again i feel
like this is like a vma night part two
where we all just get to see her be
amazing and stunning and i'm just so
excited and last time when i saw you
guys at global citizen there were there
were some water works on stage but
hopefully no water works tonight yeah
not tonight i mean i'm hoping i can suck
them in what has she told you about the
performance have you seen it so i
actually surprised myself this time i
did not see it i have purposely not gone
to any rehearsals because me and branson
we want to be really surprised but we
hear it's amazing my mom was describing
it earlier so i'm just ready to be blown
away now obviously as an artist too you
understand when you have a performance
like hers at the vmas then you come to
the amas what is the biggest challenge
about making it different well i think
because my sister is so amazing at
everything she does she constantly is
trying to one up herself
and i think that's the beautiful
challenge of a night like this another
big night like this where she can just
give it her all and do twice as amazing
which is hard to do because she's
excellent at everything so i need a
sister like you you are the best hype
woman thank you and obviously you have
your own thing going on too we've got a
just a casual little mermaid movie
coming out it's taught me a lot about
patience for sure and you told me too
that fans can look forward to the music
like first and foremost what else
definitely the music um and then you
know some little updates to the story as
well
uh yeah that's so just exciting new
stuff is it gonna be modernized a little
bit i don't know maybe a little let's
see
[Music]